Caro Roberto come stai?
io tutto bene
sono uscita con sessanta e sono molto felice
tra poco andrò in vacanza
e spero tanto di vederti
Cosa gli scrivo?
Vediamo...ehi
no per carità
umm...ciao! che fai?
no no cancella cancella
non ci siamo
cosa gli devo scrivere??
è troppo bello
ah finalmente ti ho comprato un bel astuccino
così anche se cadi non ti rompi
guarda qui cosa ti ha comprato la mamma
una fantastica cover
mi stavo allenando
a fare Britney Spears
è la sua cantante preferita
ho capito che non so dove abita
vado a colpo sicuro
però so che va sempre al chiosco me lo dicono tutti
e se non lo trovo oggi lo troverò domani
adesso intanto vado
andrò lì tutti i giorni
per forza
sto stolkerizzando come sempre e mi sto comprando il nuovo rossetto di Kylie Jenner
una che lui ama adora
stravede per sta tizia
però il rossetto ce l'ho uguale così magari...
magari un giorno sto stronzo mi calcolerà
chi è?
ciao mami
si te la passo subito
ciao mamma tutto bene
si ci facciamo una foto va bene
ciao